yeah so today I want to show you these
funky laser cut wooden tiles you can see
they all have different patterns
different squiggles they're cut out in
different sizes I'm hopefully going to
teach you a fun game that you can play
with them before we get to the tile part
you may or may not know this game we're
going to start with set this is a card
game it's beloved by mathematicians
everywhere in the world it was actually
invented in 1974 by Marshall Falco who
was a geneticist so not a mathematician
and she invented it while studying
epilepsy and German Shepherds which is
very cool I want to take just a moment
to explain the rules so if we look at
the deck here these cards are not like
normal playing cards and if we wanted to
describe them might notice that there
are four characteristics that we need to
describe so each card has a color each
card has a number of objects on it each
card has an object with a certain shape
and each object has a shading so what
are the options if I tell you there are
three then we can see what they are
every card is either purple green or red
numbers again there's three options so
we could have one object we could have
two objects or we could have three
objects all the same you'll notice
there's only one type of object per card
then shape we could have this oval we
could have squiggle or we could have a
diamond and then the shading we could
have it be empty we could have it have
stripes or our last option is it could
be solid and so in this table now we
have exactly one card for every
combination so for each card you can
only have one characteristic per quality
and so there are 81 cards total let's
see each other what are your Shuffling
no no no no you and I are playing a game
well first You're Gonna Lose I'm just
kidding Oh no you're gonna I'm gonna
lose
12 cards
I didn't do a great job shuffling but
we're gonna go with it
okay and so then we need our definition
so we're looking for is a set is a
collection of three cards such that in
each category the cards are either all
the same or all different so what that's
saying is that in each of the four
categories you either have one of each
option where they all match and it
doesn't have to be the same for each
category you could have a purple card a
green card a red card that all have one
Oval open and that would be a set
or you could have more variants so let's
see if you can find a set here okay so
and and you and I normally we would be
racing to see racing exactly right
exactly but we're not racing no I'm
gonna let you have all the time you need
so like for example these three here
that have three ovals would they be a
set or are they are they so let's look
at these yeah yeah so they're not going
to be a set they're good on the oval so
there's three ovals they all have three
and they all have different shadings but
the color is a problem because they're
neither all the same that's got to be
multiple characters exactly all right
okay well that's not it's not as easy as
I thought then no okay now I'll tell you
there is a set on the board I found one
let me well how about
I don't know
that's not a set because we've got two
lots of three
okay that's that right so that's not
that's nice because there's two threes
yeah exactly there's a there's at least
two sets on the board okay I've got a
good feeling about this one mm-hmm that
that
so I think that's a set because we've
got a three three so we've got a set on
the number criteria they're all the same
a red red red all the same all the same
we've got three different shapes so
there's three there's no shapes the same
and I want to end solid solid solid
perfect that's
a set okay so in the game I would then
keep them and you would keep them and
we'd deal out three more cards right
and then you go again okay I think
different types of sets pop out to
different types of people so I often
find much faster sets where all three
colors are different for some reason
it's just easier for me to find those
versus the one you found is all three
red cards and so I think it really
varies by what sets pop out to what
people now if you play this game
especially with mathematicians it can
get a little obnoxious how fast people
are I am actually not that fast of a set
player I'm just a big trash talker and
so part of the goal today is to show you
some harder versions of this game that
slow everybody down hang on before we go
yeah give us another set from that group
just give us another oh gosh I'm so bad
at this okay
um
my sister's gonna laugh at how long this
takes me okay so this is another set so
it's a similar flavor to the one you
found all the same color all the same
number different shape all the same
shading I would say that these two sets
are kind of the same flavor set so let's
see if we can find one with different
colors
so here's one
where we have different colors and
you'll notice I found it much faster we
have three different colors three
different shapes all one and three
different shadings so this one has more
variance than these the two sets do
somehow
nice yeah all right I get cool game yeah
cool game so part of why mathematicians
love this game
Beyond just being a really fun game to
play there is a lot of really cool math
behind it and a lot of questions that we
can ask so we're not going to dive into
that aspect there's a lot of papers you
could go read about it but for example
we could say must there always be a set
if we deal out 12 cards right because
theoretically there could be a set or
there could not be a set and that's a
very famous question of mathematics it
turns out until you deal out 21 cards
there doesn't necessarily need to be a
set present and you can also ask
questions about how many sets are there
all types of things and so to explore
any of these types of questions we want
to impose some structure on this game
mathematically and so the way we do it
is that we're going to have a funky
numbering system the mathematical term
we might say it's a sort of modular
arithmetic or finite field the basic
idea is that we assign a zero a one and
a two arbitrarily to our rows of
characteristics so arbitrarily we say
that purple zero having one is a zero
oval zero open a zero and so on and so
forth for one and two but we impose this
funny rule that one plus one plus one is
actually equal to zero in this
arithmetic so for example if I add one
plus one then I get two but if I add one
plus two plus two then I would normally
get five but every time we see three we
cancel it out so this is actually equal
to two it's modular arithmetic exactly
mod three um and so with this now for a
card
well we can
assign to it a four Tuple a vector where
we put in the number correspond to the
character so let's do this card here so
this card is red so its color entry is a
two because red is two and then there
are two of them so what number comes
next that's a one and then we have
squiggle so it's a one again and its
shading is stripe so it's a one again so
we would call this card the two red
squiggle stripes the vector or the four
Tuple two one one one and so this this
will now give us a nice space that we
can study and we often say that this
would live in like f three to the four
so this is just the three here is
reminding us that we're working mod 3
and the four is saying that we have four
qualities so we have now this dictionary
right so we have our cards that we
described using these English words and
we now have a tuple and so what's cool
about this math system is that a set
will correspond to three vectors or
quadruples in F sub three to the four
that's sum to zero and why is this the
case well if we think about what it
means to be all different right then
that means you have a zero a one and a
two showing up in that entry of your
vector and in our special math zero plus
one plus two is three which we've said
is zero and if you're all the same then
you either look like zero plus zero plus
zero which is zero one plus one plus one
is equal to zero or two plus two plus
two is equal to zero so if you're all
the same in a category then you also get
a zero in that entry when you add your
your vectors across and so we get this
really nice correspondence
mathematically where if you want to know
what a set is then you're really looking
for three vectors in this space that's
up to zero just to be clear when I say
zero I mean zero zero zero zero so the
vector length is four four entries for
our four characteristics but a card
gives corresponds to one vector so if we
want three cards we're all
the characteristics are the same or
different then that means we have three
vectors where each entry of the vector
sums two zero
okay so the one you found so we have so
let's do our Tuple so what's this card
well we have red and then we have three
and then we have oval and we have solids
we again have red again have three now
we have diamond and then we have solid
and then we have red three quiggle solid
so now we sum these the way that we sum
across a vector is that we sum each
entry so two plus two plus two is six
but that's a multiple of three so that
gives us a zero again two plus two plus
two gives us zero zero plus two plus one
well we had that case here we get zero
and two plus two plus two is zero I'm
being a little sloppy with my equal sign
here I'm saying equal in this
in this space if you had special goggles
that let you see the cards as their
vectors rather than as they appear would
that make the game easier or harder
that's a great question and so actually
that I think this is part of why
mathematicians love this game is that
you actually can think about it in terms
of the cards you can think about I would
say this is an algebraic interpretation
so we're thinking about it in terms of
algebra or you could actually think
about it in terms of geometry where in
fact if we lined up for example all of
the red cards that are diamonds then you
could notice that sets are exactly the
lines showing up in that space and so we
actually have another definition that's
equivalent so to answer your question I
think it probably depends on who's
playing some people are probably really
fast at the algebra some people might be
really fast with geometry I do think at
the end of the day that the cards are
often the most fun way to play and so
I'll talk about this a little bit with
these new variations of the game but
what you're really looking for is a game
that is fun to play and interesting
mathematically all right so now I want
to talk about some generalizations of
this game that I actually invented with
two friends when I was in grad school so
the friends are Jonah ostroff and
lucasfan meter
um we just we love this game and we're
very competitive so we like to find new
harder versions of the game how can we
generalize this game to other
mathematical structures so if we think
back to our to our original game right
then we said we were over this F3 to the
four that's kind of our structure what
do we need to make set and I'll put in
quotes because I mean with other
structures the first thing we need is we
need some collection of elements we need
some card so in this case the elements
are these four tuples with the numbers
zero one and two and our cards are
normal set cards we need some way to
combine our elements in our normal set
game we took our two vectors and we
could add them component wise and so if
you give me two cards I have a
mathematical way to combine them so in
whatever elements we come up with we
need a way to combine them then we need
some sort of Target where something
we're trying to get to so again a normal
game where we're trying to get to is
zero zero zero zero that's what we're
trying to add our elements to so this is
some type of Target element we could
think of it as an identity or zero
depending on what type of elements
you're working with and then lastly we
want to know that for any two elements
there is a way to get to the Target
right because if you've picked two cards
and there wasn't a third card that could
complete the set it wouldn't make the
game very fun so Bare Bones this is kind
of the minimal list of things we need
and in math we might say one one
structure that satisfies this if we took
a group so a group has some sort of
elements it has an operation that allows
you to combine your elements it has an
identity element and you can always if
you pick a group element you can always
find a way back to the identity so what
I want to talk about for the rest of the
time are different groups that we can
play set on and there are actually a lot
of them but today we're going to talk
about a specific type of group it's
called a permutation group I'm now going
to explain to you what these funky lines
are and so they're actually
corresponding to permutation so what do
I mean by permutation well we're going
to simplify things and we're just going
to say we're looking at some collection
of numbers integers one to some number n
but we'll just say three so one two
three
and a permutation is a bijective map
between these sets so it means that
every number on the left gets mapped to
exactly one number on the right and in
particular that means that every number
on the right will be mapped to by
exactly one number on the left so for
example we could send one to one two to
two three to three so that's kind of a
boring permutation a more interesting
one might be we could send one to two
two to one three to three so these are
going to be our elements so our elements
are going to be these Maps between sets
of numbers and so this group in
particular we might call S Sub 3 because
we're looking at three numbers here
and so now I said we need to build a
combined permutation so if this is our
first permutation how can we combine it
with another one well we just do what's
most natural and we concatenate them and
then for a second permutation one goes
to two two goes to three and three goes
up to one so then if we want to combine
them we just Trace along the line
completely and so we'd say well one
first goes to two and then 2 goes to
three so one ends up going all the way
down to three two goes up to one one
goes down to two so two goes to itself
and then 3 goes to 3 and 3 goes up to
one we now have elements we have a way
to combine them I wrote down our Target
and you'll just have to believe me for
now that for any two elements we can
always find a way back to our Target and
it comes from the fact that these are
going to be groups okay so now the punch
line here is that we can play this game
and so on each of these cards
you have one of these permutations that
show up and so now the way we play set
is that
you're looking for some combination of
three
that when you put them together you get
back the identity permutation
okay but what's interesting about this
version is that order matters so if you
think back to our original there's no
ordering on these cards but there is an
ordering for here so once we deal them
out you have to find a subset in this
order that compose the identity so if we
take these two so one okay so it's going
to be this one
when we compose these three together you
can trace your finger along the one it
goes down and back up
down it comes back up three it goes up
and then back down so this is what we
would call a set in this game what are
the red dots down the bottom there
that's a great question so the red dots
at the bottom correspond to whether or
not we can write this as an even or odd
number of swapping of lines so there's a
lot of theory behind these types of
elements and so it just helps for
example you can prove that any set here
has to have an even number of red dots
so it helps you when you're trying to
find them because it's much harder in
this game I want the lines the position
of the start point of the lines to start
and end to start and end in the sense
that's what you want that's your
identity yeah
okay well that sounds hard it is hard
and to tell you the truth this one is
quite easy because there's only three
lines so let me show you the tiles now
we can do this for a lot of different
sets of permutations so on these cells
you'll notice they have four positions
one to four
instead of one to three and it makes the
game much harder so with just three
starting and ending spots you have six
cards with four starting ending spots
you have 24 cards so these are laser cut
and you'll notice the wedge at the
bottom isolate this one right you'll
notice there's a notch here and it's the
same reason that you can write this
permutation as exactly swapping two
lines so we have this one is harder to
see but you could write this one as well
as an odd number of line swapping so it
has a wedge and so the way we play is we
deal out that imposes an ordering on our
tiles and then we're looking for a
subset now we play this game's made up
so you can play however you like but we
play three or more tiles it's very
restrictive to say you have to have
exactly three tiles so for example so
these five tiles which you'll notice I
kept the order the same we can trace our
finger one goes down to the spot three
up to two down to four up to two back up
to one two goes up to one across down
down up and so you can trace across that
you do in fact have the identity
permutation across all five tiles it
feels to me like you've made the hardest
game ever like I feel like I would look
I would look at a bunch of those tiles
and it would take me a year in my head
to to make those paths yeah so this is
actually probably the hardest of the
tiles I'm going to show you
so this one I
and the interesting thing though is that
the tiles are really fun to play with
even if you're not playing by the rules
so to speak just because you learned so
much about how these permutations work
so I would agree I think this is the
hardest of the tiles that we have so for
my so if if you've got a bunch of them
in front of you even you can't see the
paths there are other people who are
better than I am so I have seen students
or other
um fine sets
and sets it let me show you the other
tiles because I think they're actually
they get more complicated mathematically
but actually easier to play so the next
one we have here I have them on paper
first we have two games at the same time
of our original S3 set so the red and
the blue games don't know anything about
each other
you're just playing red and blue at the
same time which makes it a lot harder
and so to win you have to have a
simultaneous set on top and bottom crazy
now I have seen people find these sets
live but you can see the tiles and again
if you look really closely you'll notice
that there are wedges at the top and the
bottom to again that really helps when
you're looking for these you can join
them together so you'll notice like this
one this bottom has the little circle
here
and this one has a little Diamond up top
and that corresponds to the fact that
they're Transitions and then just to see
how they combine these ones if you
combine these two you get this and so
for this one I actually just have a set
pre-done so we won't even be looking for
it
we can just see because I think these
are really hard although I will say
some people find these really fast
so if you look here on the top
we Trace along we get our Top Line works
our second line works and then we
automatically get our third line for
free if we have the right number of
wedges and then similarly for the bottom
hopefully this is a set
yep yep okay we might call this S3 cross
S3 set which is saying that we have two
copies of our S3 set and they're
independent of each other so there's no
relationship between the two so now we
actually come to my favorite version of
this is called wreath product set and it
was actually suggested by Josh mundinger
at a summer program that I work at these
cards look very similar to our ones
before so recall these were our S3 cards
so you'll notice they have the same sort
of S3 permutation but now they have
these blue dots as well the rule is that
if you have two marbles on a strand they
cancel out so every time you have two
marbles they cancel out so if we wanted
to combine these cards I claim it's
equal to this card over here
so let's see why well on our first
strand we come across it starts and ends
in the one position so it goes straight
across and the two marbles cancel out so
there's no marble left the second line
it goes across up back down to the third
position so we have two going to three
and there's one marble and then the
third line goes up to two and across so
the third line goes from three to two
and it has three marbles so we cancel we
cancel out so to find a set in these
cards we want the identity permutation
in S3 plus an even number of marbles on
each Strand and so these tiles I think
are very pleasing the way that they're
laser cut out so again you see the
marbles are these holes on the right
side the wedges are still there
so I have a deal for us
now I say this is partly my favorite
because this one is actually playable I
think in terms of just staring at it for
a little while
so to save us time I think two three
um
five and seven make a set
so if we combine those together
then we have one it goes down to the
bottom across back up two marbles two
goes back to its starting place two
marbles three goes up down to its
starting place and two marbles so that
would be a set here what's really
interesting about this going back again
to your question about playability is
that this game of S4 right
is actually
equivalent to a subset of these wreath
product tiles so it lives inside this
game but somehow this game with with our
DOT is way more easy to keep track of in
your eye like it's way easier to play
compared to this I find this impossible
these are I find quite fun and so I
think another fun aspect of these is
just when you're trying to learn about
these types of groups mathematically you
learn all sorts of properties just from
playing with the tiles
if you look on the website there are
some versions back to this original game
of set some twists on that as well as
some other visualizations of games that
already exist yeah video description and
I also should say for me
as a math educator I think one of the
biggest utilities of these games besides
being fun is they have been really
helpful for me in the classroom I think
where just when you're starting to get
familiar with these types of more
abstract ideas in math it's really
helpful for example with these wreath
product sets it's a really nice
visualization of what's called a
semi-direct product and so I think the
exercise of writing out the math to go
along with the tiles you learn so much